there is a fine line with logging of not
making your life completely about
YouTube because you could we don't film
everything I'll say the camera is
probably almost with us like 90 of the
time so we always have the camera but we
try to keep things as organic as we
possibly can
I'm excited because I'm actually a fan
of good simple living that's right I am
I'm a huge RV fan I'm a huge off-grid
fan and somehow on a on you know uh uh
11 p.m watching YouTube your channel
scrolled across my YouTube feed and I
was so intrigued it was when you guys
first moved to your farm so I want to
introduce to you guys uh Melissa and
Jeremy from good simple living I'm so
excited to have you guys on the podcast
today thank you for having us yeah thank
you so much so one of the reasons that I
got in touch with you and wanted you
guys to be on the show is because you
are doing all the things that we teach
here at think media I don't even know if
you knew who think media was or what did
you hear okay you did good that makes me
happy I should have asked that prior to
um but you're doing all the things and I
would and we have a lot of our audience
who wants to start vlogging but they
don't really understand like how to do
it and you guys have become Mass
successful I believe you'll hit a
million subscribers within the next year
you guys are making a full-time living
doing YouTube and you're just sharing
your life through vlogging so we're
gonna dive into that today we're going
to go through your five tips but first I
need to know though Melissa Jeremy how
did you even get started in this YouTube
World I'd love for people to know a
little bit about your past and what your
YouTube channel is currently about
well I started the channel I guess what
three four four years ago and I actually
thought it was way before that but well
as far as devoting ourselves to it yeah
so we actually devoted ourselves to it
about two and a half years ago but I
started the channel four years ago
because I was selling vegetables and
chicken eggs and stuff out of my yard
and I wanted people to feel a connection
to their food so I just started it as a
gardening Channel and as like a backyard
meat channel of like raising chickens or
rabbits to uh for sustainability and
then I wanted people that came and
bought kale from to see their kale be
planted and watch it grow because I
thought that it would help them feel
like for those that couldn't Garden that
they were gardening along with us and
then they would come get that food and
it was more of just a community thing
like in my small local community and I
only had like a handful of people
watching it but then I planted or I
planted a uh posted a video about rabbit
and then I just walked away from it I
didn't even check on it for six months
and then when I went back and logged
into YouTube I had like 10 000
subscribers and the video had a million
views and I was like what what happened
so then I just started to feed the
channel after that
amazing so you get a viral video about
rabbits you know and people think oh
I've got to figure this whole thing out
and you're like actually I just started
making content around what I was doing
now you Jeremy you already had a career
and then how did you become a YouTuber
um honestly ironically enough when
Melissa started all this it was without
my knowledge um I was a full-time coming
soccer at the time and when she finally
put me into the fact that he had started
a YouTube channel I kind of rolled my
eyes and scoffed at it thinking that it
wasn't a good use of our time and uh
like she said come to find out we
checked it randomly one day we had a
bunch of views on there our channel was
not monetized or anything like that and
uh so from then on I kind of saw the
potential in it and said hey you know
yeah maybe this is a work while Endeavor
to kind of poured ourselves into it at
that point yeah it's been such a cool
Journey because you guys actually
basically sold everything in one state
moved on to this giant plot of land in
gorgeous country of I won't say where
unless you guys do you guys say where it
is yeah okay
um I just didn't know if I knew that
just from doing massive research on you
guys or if you actually do tell people
that
um but you guys moved out to Idaho and
you started building a house I mean by
yourselves but with other contract
directors but you started building your
life in Idaho talk about like how
YouTube became a part of that Journey as
that whole thing took place
well kind of like you said when we moved
here we didn't have anything we didn't
have any infrastructure set up we were
actually living out of a camp trailer at
the time we slowly moved that trailer
into a barn that we got built here on
the property and then uh took on the
task of building out the living space
which we are in currently
um that was a long project required a
lot of us and along the way we were just
kind of documenting and showing what it
is that we were having to do for
ourselves to to make life here on this
land possible yeah but as far as YouTube
went
um in order to move out into the middle
of nowhere and start building a house
which was seven days a week building we
had to come up with a way of funding it
and funding our lives and providing for
our children because we have four kids
as well so it's not like it's just us
and we can eat Top Ramen and live in a
tent we have four kids and so we had to
come up with a way of funding it so I
said you know what let's quit our jobs
and let's be all in on YouTube and it's
going to work we're going to make it
work and we're going to grind and get
better because we weren't very good at
filming I was terrible at editing you
know I didn't know anything I had never
done anything like that I mean if you
watch our original videos they're
they're pretty rough I mean they look
like somebody who's pointing at camera
and stuff and I feel my feet and just
weird things and so I'm like I'm gonna
get better and every single video I'm
gonna try to get a little better and a
little better and I'm gonna get better
with the shots and things so it was just
an all-in thing like sink or swim and we
couldn't think because we had kids so we
painted ourselves into a corner and had
to make it work said make it happen yeah
I think if you're happy and half out
like I was in Washington it's just so
hard to grow that way because you've got
work and other obligations and you're
not devoted to YouTube and to the art of
making a good video and that whole it's
just hard to grow that way at least with
the way we do things right it is
possible I think it just it frees you up
like she said to to really
pour yourself into what it is that
you're doing when you have more time
yeah
it's hard to quit your job and just say
okay we're going to be video creators
now so that's what we did but I'm in no
way advocating other people to go do
that it's so incredible I I'm not
advocating that as either except that I
think that you guys you you do what we
call burn the boats you just burn the
boats yeah there actually is no going
back we are marking ourselves as video
content creators we're gonna figure out
how to make this work and I think having
that mentality of it not being a hobby
but actually being a career a
sustainable income for your family I
think from seeing uh you guys progress
over the last couple years that actually
to me was a pivotal point where where
you started to actually see like what
are we doing that can make income we're
gonna have a conversation about how you
guys are full-time content creators in
just a bit on the second part of this uh
interview but I've got to know you know
when you decided to go all in what were
some of the fears and insecurities about
putting your life out on camera yeah
I'd say the biggest fear was failure
um and taking on this tremendous risk
and letting ourselves and more
importantly our children down
um and our extended family it uh
improving them right it was a it was a
massive massive risk doing what we did
um I think that was my biggest fear
personally especially if the kind of
Breadwinner of our family yeah because
yeah I mean I think a lot of the
pressure was on him because he's going
to quit the full-time career
um and it was kind of like if this
doesn't work out it plays out publicly
like not only for our family and friends
to see but for any for anyone to see
like these people went out there and
they tried the Sun and they had to you
know return with their tails between
their legs and that's that was a fear
there's insecurity in that it's a very
vulnerable position when you put
yourself online and have kids play all
publicly like you mentioned yeah
major major fear of ours coming into it
yeah and then privacy and normalcy for
our kids so like originally you didn't
see the kids very much in the videos
because we didn't want to just change
everything about their lives and shove a
camera in their face and even now
they're not really on unless they choose
to be
and some of them really like to be on
camera and some of them don't so when
they come out and they want to be on
camera we film them but
we don't like if they're upset or
they're crying or they're sick and we've
had situations where We've Ended up in
the emergency room for stitches and it
would have been so easy to shove a
camera in his face make it the thumbnail
get a million views but we've made the
decision a long time ago that we were
never going to use them in that way so
there's a there's a thin line with
family vlogging yeah really really good
I I actually really appreciate that you
guys honor your children that way
um because I I actually think it
benefits the storyline you know the Vlog
isn't about your kids or the the whole
content isn't just about your kids which
I think is is a mistake that a lot of
family vloggers fall into where as your
guyses to me as a viewer really is about
this journey of building this um Farm
building this you know uh a ranch what
are you guys calling it is it a farm is
it a ranch what are we building here
it's kind of more of a hobby farm for us
it's a pretty small operation yeah yeah
but it's that idea that that actually is
the focal point and then you've got
characters around it which is the family
so um let's jump into some of your tips
because people want to become vloggers
that's a huge thing uh you know Casey
neistat was someone who really
established that uh several years ago
and so many people want to do that and
actually here at think media it's not
the first thing we tell people to do
because as you guys have figured this
out it's hard right it's hard to tell
stories it's hard to continue this on a
very regular basis but you guys have
really I think unlocked the code for how
to do vlogging right and so uh Jeremy
the first tip you had is using what
you've got now let's talk about what
equipment did you start with and what
equipment do you guys have now and how
has that changed when you talk about
like just use what you have and get
started yeah it's just a matter of not
making excuses and uh you know trying to
find solutions for every problem so in
the very beginning we have a horrible
DSLR camera that we use with awful awful
raw audio that was really difficult to
make out uh we were taking that really
poor quality footage dumping it into a
Windows Movie Maker I believe was the
name of the program and that's what we
were using for all of our very rough
editing once again so
um rather than being hey you know I
don't have the proper camera that is
recommended that I'm seeing everywhere
online uh we use that very basic DSLR
but that's what we had and from there we
transitioned to just our smartphones we
didn't have high quality smartphones I
think the first one that we started
using was an S10 Samsung S10 yeah which
again was an improvement uh both
visually with footage and audio wise but
it still was pretty rough we then
transitioned to wondershare filmora was
a program that we are still now using to
this day yeah all of our video editing
and it's just kind of grown and evolved
over time and rather than you know
getting up on the fact that I don't have
this microphone I don't have this camera
we just always Embrace and use whatever
it is I've had access to yeah and your
skill set is what your skill set is so
instead of trying and I think people can
become very easily overwhelmed by taking
a bunch of film courses watching this
fancy editing getting fancy editing
software that's extremely overwhelming I
mean I looked at one of them and it had
all these different lines there was like
five audio lines and I was like ah it's
so like I don't know how to do this and
I just instantly shut down instead of
just starting with something that made
sense something that was easy user
friendly and then as you perfect that or
as you become comfortable with that add
one thing that's my thing like every
video add one thing get good at that
then add one more thing
yeah really good and I I appreciate to
even you know you guys you don't have a
studio setup it's not like you've got
like the best Lighting in the I mean
you're literally just vlogging your life
inside outside all weather conditions
inside with dust outside with you know
so it's this idea of just what do you
already have and how can you tell a
story with it and um that actually goes
into the second tip which is to be your
authentic self Melissa has that been
something that you've really had to work
on over the years of of doing this and
how have you applied that to this
successful Vlog that you guys have yeah
I mean it was kind of a hard transition
I was a teacher back in the day and so I
kind of have that that teacher how to
miss about me and so all of my videos
before were how to's like how to prune a
tomato plant how to process a chicken
how to cook a rabbit so and it was all
like it so and I had to get off of that
how to
the mindset and just go back into just
acting normal and when you're talking to
a camera you're not there's no person
there so it's hard to be natural and
just be yourself and like that yeah it's
easy to say hey be yourself but being
yourself and being yourself on camera
are two entirely different things and
kind of like Melissa mentioned is the
same thing for me all the police
officers for 14 years so I had this way
of kind of carrying myself and speaking
I still do it every when I watch myself
on on videos and I'm like why are you
explaining things the way you're
explaining them but um yeah it's
different and it's a skill again that
evolves along the way and it comes with
constant refinement and trying to
improve and get better at what it is
that we're doing and devoting ourselves
to yeah and you do just become more
comfortable as it goes so I think being
authentic goes a really long way and
once you can establish
even the smallest level of comfort with
being on camera as long as you can also
be yourself I think that translates and
comes across really well to viewers yeah
I've seen people uh
they'll they want to come across as like
being very safe and family friendly and
everything but they necessarily they
they aren't necessarily at home and so
then they create this character and then
they have to maintain this character and
it's so much better to just like we'll
crack dirty jokes and we'll do things
that are inappropriate and stuff because
that's how we act like if you come hang
out with us if you come have a beer with
us so we're going to say something
inappropriate and so we just figure you
know what let's build our Channel and
our audience around
people that are comfortable with who we
actually are and then we never have to
pretend to be something else
I think that really authentically being
the number two authentic self that comes
across very authentically on your guys's
Channel I feel like you express your
values without expressing your values
you share your relationship without
sharing your relationship so I think
that
um you know it comes with the practice
like you said Jeremy being a police
officer this like a camera in your face
now it's kind of weird right but over
time if you do it more and more and you
just kind of you just kind of see that
it's um it that whatever whoever you
normally are uh just be that on camera
and it'll come through right it'll be
it'll be a part of that now part of that
also is this idea especially for
vloggers a lot of the advice out there
is like build a storyline and I think
that that actually isn't good quality
advice for vloggers but I think that
there's this idea that you should just
be showing as you go and I know that's
tip number three
um and so Melissa talk about like how do
you guys build um you know are you
filming all day long and it's you know
17 hours of footage and you're cutting
it down to 20 minutes are you seeing
different moments to record what does
that look like as you show as you go
um so sometimes stuff will happen and
it's like let's record this and then
other times stuff's happening where I'm
going I should be recording this but
then there's that that line between
family and personal life and so
sometimes we're just like no you know
like Christmas morning you guys aren't
going to see Christmas morning because
that's for us and so there's a there's a
fine line with vlogging of
of not making your life completely about
YouTube because you could like you could
film everything and yes you're going to
end up with this crazy blog you're not
going to miss a single thing but at the
same time you have to have real life and
and so that's been a balance and I think
again if it was just Jeremy and I we
wouldn't worry about it as much but
being with the kids it's a huge concern
with not filming absolutely everything
yeah we don't film everything I'll say
the camera is probably almost with us
like 90 of the time so we always have
the camera but we try to keep things as
organic as we possibly can so we don't
go into recording our newest video with
um like specific shots in mind or we
don't storyboard things out we just kind
of take the camera out have a rough idea
of what it is that we're trying to
accomplish and we do our best in the
moment um to keep things again organic
and and capture them in a way
um and with a style that we we like and
we prefer yeah so there's challenges in
that like if you do a lot of vloggers
will do their thumbnail and their title
before they even start recording and
then they form the video around that we
don't do that we actually just but then
there are times when we're like do we
even have a story here you know is there
does this even go together but it goes
together in editing it always does but
we've gone on vacations where we didn't
storyboard and we didn't plan things or
activities and then as we're leaving the
vacation we're going did we even get a
video so there's
I think maybe a happy medium between the
two and that's probably something that
we're going to work on to get better at
and we definitely don't have this all
figured out are you ready to start or
grow your YouTube channel do you feel
stuck and need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
YouTube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
yeah and as you are showing as you go I
notice that there's multiple camera
angles a lot of times
um so is that Uh something's happening
and you're like grab the camera Jeremy
move it over here or is it like let's
set up two cameras what does that look
like for you practically that's part of
that style that we liked where we want
to capture something but we don't want
to capture it from the same vantage
point for the entirety of whatever it is
that's unfolding so oftentimes
especially when we're in the middle of
like a build project Melissa will
literally shout at me if she has a
camera in her hand stop hold on one
second and then she'll Shuffle over
somewhere just to capture her from a
different angle and then she'll be like
you know she'll coo me back in and say
okay go ahead and I'll finish my cut or
whatever it is I'm doing so we've got I
think we've got pretty good with that
the workflow lies but yeah we use just a
single camera so when you're seeing all
those different angles that's because
one of us is running around trying to
capture for different angles yeah that's
so fun well props to you guys because I
was like what do you have like three D
are you employing your kids to be a part
of this like I mean all the different
angles and I think that also you know
we'll talk about
um uh one of the other tips but really
to me that you guys are really great
storytellers and I've noticed too
um that a lot of times you'll when you
say oh sometimes we don't feel like we
have a video you do voice-overs that I
think really helps to draw the whole
video together and really creates a
story rather than it just being a bunch
of different shots of you guys you know
putting in the kitchen counters or
whatever that looks like so I think
that's really cool to see that you're uh
even when you are showing as you go
you're still using a lot of different
editing techniques
um along the way now number number four
your tip was actually don't watch other
family vloggers or don't watch other
people that are in your space now but
you do watch other YouTubers so that
you're starting to see that there's
these other options for how to be
applying different storytelling
techniques why do you think it's
important as a vlogging tip to actually
not watch your competitors
we take a tremendous amount of pride in
again trying to be ourselves and do our
own thing and carve out our own way I
think when you watch others who kind of
operate in the same Niche that you do
you run the risk of having things kind
of somewhat like infiltrate your mind
and then you you tend to try to mimic
somebody else rather than being yourself
to get back to that whole point of
trying to be your authentic self and and
you know being you all of the time that
you're on camera so
um we we come up with our own thoughts
our own ideas and try to implement them
and it's always the hope that that's
what sets us apart
from you know anyone else operating
within the same space we are yeah
there's a lot of mimicking that goes on
on YouTube and I think that that's not
the best way to start a channel like if
you're starting a channel don't copy
another Channel's name
trying to get those immediate views
because you'll always be viewed as
a copy of that channel like you should
try to set yourself apart by what makes
you unique and embrace that instead of
just copying you know like oh that
thumbnail is really cool let's let's do
that exactly don't do that go with your
own idea yeah and one of the things you
guys do while you're not following other
people in your Niche you guys are
integrated into the YouTube culture so
you're seeing other channels that are
pulling things in um and actually prior
to this we were talking about some of
those channels and I just made a
connection that you know one of those uh
um Ryan who is a huge YouTuber I'm
actually seeing now in your content and
his content even how you guys angle
certain things that I'm like oh my gosh
that makes sense now and how fast some
of your edits are
um so talk about just being a part of
the YouTube culture and how you're
pulling from other types of content yeah
I think I know it's very important to
know the space and you can order the
platform and see you know what people
respond favorably to or what we even uh
like and enjoy ourselves so like with
Ryan treynan he's a very quirky kind of
silly personality and and we kind of are
ourselves as well so of course we're
drawn to that but yeah as far as
watching other people and the things
that they do or even learning about
their creative process I think is a huge
part of actually doing YouTube for
yourself you kind of have to somewhat be
a student of the game and have uh some
semblance or an idea of you know the
things that that work well with an
audience things really important yeah I
think there's a big difference between
watching videos and and seeing how they
can tell a story without saying okay now
we're going to do this and then do it
now we're going to do this and then do
it so we're trying to get better at that
because that's completely how we came
out the gate we were like now we're
going to install this stove pipe now
that the stovepipe it is it like and
that's a hard thing to break out of
that's a natural thing to want to do and
so we're trying to get better at
telling those stories through actions
and so we end up with a lot less talking
and more organic natural talking and
making videos is a skill and if there's
anything to be drawn from someone else
and watching the way that they they do
things or what their process is there's
there's a lot to be gleaned from others
so I think being a student of the game
again is is of the utmost importance
yeah like we had our kids take the Casey
neistat film course it was an excellent
course and he talks all about
storytelling and how to tell the story
and how to like I love the when he
something I've never been able to pull
off when he's
saying something and he says it in 10
different locations but it's one
seamless sentence it is incredible and
he talks about how he does that and how
many times he records each word and then
he tries to put it all together in
editing and I tried something like that
once and it was not good but I mean like
when I see him do it I'm like oh that's
so beautiful it's such it's something
that I think a lot of viewers don't
notice but creators notice it like wow
that's incredible that you can do that
inspiring yeah so yeah we watch a lot
Casey neistat comes out with a new video
we're like play you know we want to see
everything we get
yeah you put on this new lens right it's
like um it's it's like before you used
to watch YouTube and it was just
entertaining and it was fun you didn't
really understand it then you become a
player in the game and you're like oh
did you say they did that oh yeah
I'll be watching videos next to my
husband and I'll be like dang that took
a long time he's like can we just watch
this video I'm like no I want to honor
that I understand that whatever that
shot was or that scene was that took a
lot of time to actually be a part of
that so I love that you guys are coming
at YouTube uh with that Creator lens on
as you're watching and seeing what other
um creators are doing and then lastly
your tip which is probably
um coming from a teacher heart as well
Melissa is you know always try something
new and I think it's really you know
inspirational to see that your Vlogs
when they first started are not what
they are today and really we're gonna
get into more of how um in the part two
of how you guys have actually made this
you're living this is how you're
supporting your family and this is your
career now
um and so much more is going to come out
of part two but I would just love to hit
on this as a vlogger why is it important
to always be trying something new and
experimenting as you're creating content
yeah um well so I always tell people
always try something new but always try
one thing one thing and per video and
that's so you don't become overwhelmed
because if you come overwhelmed you shut
down and you're far more likely to quit
if it's not fun and you feel like you're
failing or you feel like I can't do this
so it's like start a video and then I'll
say
like I just started doing this you know
the new man thing and the zoom out thing
where you barely noticed it I started
that I don't know six months ago or
something but I started with one video
like this video I'm gonna do a couple
Zoom ins I think I did like two and he's
like fancy and now it's like if if you
watch one of our videos there's so many
there's like 90 of them now because now
I'm comfortable with that I understand
like approach leaving when to use it
yeah exactly when it's too much you
don't want to be like so
you know just learning something and
then once you have that try something
else try a new transition in the next
video but never stop using the new skill
and then all of a sudden you have this
whole collection of skills for editing
that you just learned one at a time
instead of trying to do all of them as a
new blogger so and then every video just
try to make it a little bit better and a
little bit better we always want to
watch a video three months later and
hate it so like that was bad like oh
that was so bad look at what we did
three months ago you should always be
your own worst critic and I feel like
you should always be kind of unhappy
with the videos you made in the past and
that way you know you're progressing I
love that tip I I think that's really
critical for any content creator to be
showing progress to be trying new things
to be experimenting
um I just got off of a meeting right
before this where we were like the
podcast needs to change because we were
noticing that our analytics were telling
us that people only like these types of
videos and so I think it's it's really
important too to to analyze you know
what's working what's not working and
how can you be incorporating new things
so um well I'm really excited what is my
last question for this uh segment is uh
or for this episode is um someone is
listening right now and you know they've
picked up their camera a few times
they're still kind of nervous they're
trying to figure out this whole YouTube
thing they want to make this something
that is a reality for them and their
family they want to either pay off their
student loans they want to be able to
you know move States and build a house
they want to they really want to figure
out how to make YouTube their career
um what would be your leaving advice for
a brand new content creator who wants to
pick up blogging and have that be the
direction that they go
I would say get started get going jump
in
um do it and realize that you may not be
great at it in the beginning it's a
constant process of
refinement a lot of self-reflection and
self motivation just trying to improve
over time you may not be great about the
gate but really the only way to get
better is to start doing that right yeah
get started and apply yourself to it
apply yourself to learning and getting
better and
discouraged because it's so so slow at
the beginning
and then it's a Snowball Effect like the
bigger it gets the faster it grows but
in the beginning it's slow I mean we
first got monetized you don't get a
payout till you get a hundred dollars
and it would take us three or four
months to get a payout which meant we
were making 25 a month you used to joke
that we'd make dozens of dollars
and that was on for two years so if you
give up you're never gonna get that you
have to just keep working but you have
to keep improving you can't become
complacent and say well this is how my
videos are this is all I'm capable of
then you're not gonna grow
so so good well thank you guys for being
on this episode The Next Episode we're
going to talk about all about how you
guys became full-time content creators
how you're using YouTube to support your
family and I've got some questions
around how you guys are specifically
doing brand deals in your videos that
are helping to uh monetize
um the content that you're creating so
I'm excited for part two in just a few
moments
[Music]